And the beginning of this lesson, we talked about classes and methods, and
about the fact that a method should always belong to a particular class, who's
objects are responsible for carrying it out. Sometimes that's not as easy as it
sounds. Let's go back to a program that you saw in lesson five. In the elevator
demo, we write in a number, and then we first checked whether it was a valid
integer, whether it was within range, and only then were we able to do any work
with it. It would be nice if we could put all of this code in a separate
method. And then I would like to call that method, in somewhat this fashion, so
I want to read a number between 1 and 18, I want to read it from this scanner
and I want to have the prompt to be floor. And of course the reason I want that
is, then I can reuse the readBetween method again, when I want to read some
other value that's maybe between one and 100 and maybe it's the temperature. So
like so many of us, the readBetween method is probably wondering, where do I
belong? Well in which class do you think the readBetween method should be put?
The system class? The scanner class? The ElevatorDemo, or maybe somewhere else.
Just think about it and give me your best guess.